le photographe helmut newton célèbre
dans le monde entier a été victime d'un
accident il est mort hier à los angeles
à l'âge de 83 ans
cet artiste né à berlin était connu pour
ses photos de femmes sculpturales
provocante dominatrice il laisse une
oeuvre complète michel mompontet sa
silhouette élégante l'éternel jeune
homme était presque aussi connu que son
oeuvre sonne oeuvre el mout newton des
femmes forcément inaccessible hautaine
et l'argent le luxe et la domination
helmut newton était le diable pour les
mouvements féministes normal des
milliers de clichés papier glacé comme
un paparazzi de luxe dans une jatte 7
déglingué où la femme devient un objet
de désir de soultz à la surface envoie
des gens très beau très glacée avec des
bijoux qui coûte très cher et des
manteaux de fourrure et au fond il ya
aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de noirceur
et beaucoup de questionnements dans tout
ça hughton photographe de stars elles
lui font confiance ils et de leur monde
newton lui est fasciné par le pouvoir et
par son spectacle ambiguë ou trompeurs
mais derrière ces clichés archi connu il
ya le travail d'un photographe exigeant
et surdoué méticuleux et modeste newton
avoue être daltonien et voyeur sans
problème
dieudonné le monde du glamour de la jet
set c'est le sien qui le fait qu'il
honore qui le décore ces clichés se
vendent à 100 mille dollars pièce le
petit reporter du singapour times a
beaucoup grandi star des magazines de
luxe
il devient star des musées sur la fin de
sa vie où ses photos s'expose où l'on
parle non plus de scoops médard on parle
non plus de chance oui de talent l'art
mais aussi le business est plus que
fructueux pub 5000 $ par jour le prix
d'une griffe d'une signature en or la
sienne mais helmut newton n'avait jamais
oublié le petit juif de berlin qu'il
avait été admis new york stater celui
qui en 38 avaient fui la répression
nazie vers la liberté
aujourd'hui dans un accident de voiture
il est mort cette mort qui est venu le
chercher et est sûrement vêtu de cuir